we know that there is a lot of energy it's
very exciting but but the energy is because
of the lockdowns it's because of the schools
being shut down I mean you heard in the debate
she came out and she said our schools were only
locked down for three months which is a total
lie even even just today at this rally we had a
young man who he must be in high school probably
about 16 17 years old and he said I listened to
her say that I was out of school for a year and
a half in Ann Arbor this is when you have the
students who are the ones that are standing up
and seeing that these politicians are being
dishonest I think that's a really interesting
turn because now politicians have to realize
that they're not just being watched by adults
that what they're doing is being watched by
kids because kids have more access to the
news and politics than they ever have before
and so when children are watching you and they
hear you say something dishonest I mean those
those are the folks that are going to call you
out every time right the kids turn around
and they say oh this the governor's lying
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is the
Republican nominee for governor of the great
state of Michigan Tudor Dixon tutor welcome to the
Reuben report so thank you for having me well I'm
very happy to have you on I have to get two things
off my chest before we start number one I don't
like Gretchen Whitmer very much and I've made
a lot of fun of her in the last two years or so
and then number two I did not know much about you
until about two weeks ago after uh once I watched
you in the debate and I was super impressed so
for the for the people that don't know too much
of you about you outside of Michigan uh can
we do a little a little Tudor Dixon 101 first
yes absolutely so a little bit about me I am a
mom of four daughters so I have kids that went
through the whole school pandemic crisis and was
walking alongside the other parents during that
time but I think something that most people don't
know about me is that I'm a businesswoman I come
from the steel manufacturing world my family had
a steel foundry in Michigan and so I worked on the
shop floor for many years went from the steel
casting industry into the forging industry so
I had worked in heavy equipment mining railroad
military equipment and then with the automotive
industry so I learned our Michigan automotive
industry but then about five years ago I had a
friend come to me and say I'm not sure if you know
what's happening in our schools and at that time
the concern was just this anti-American message
I mean you know you talk about it all the time
and kind of the indoctrination that was happening
in schools so we created a media company at that
time to counteract CNN 10 that's in our middle
and high schools and we started that that expanded
into working on political campaigns and then
working on a a conservative conservative Network
and through that we said you know what grutch we
started going through the pandemic watching what
Gretchen Whitmer was doing and said who's going
to take this woman out of office we've got to
take our state back and that was kind of our We
the People moment when I said well let's do this
and see what it takes and so far it's been an
interesting ride but we are really we feel the
support of the people in the state of Michigan
the campaign is really thriving the momentum is
there we just had a rally and I think about five
people came up to me and said I've never attended
a political rally before but I am just so jazzed
up for this election so we feel the momentum on
the ground and it's really exciting I think my
business background was kind of unexpected from
Gretchen Whitmer she saw me as more of a political
commentator and I guess thought that potentially
I wouldn't be able to go toe-to-toe with her
when it comes to the debate and understand the
the private sector the way I do and I think that
was unexpected for her and I feel like we maybe
had her on her heels a bit Yeah well I love the
story there because I think this is the theme
right now with this new crop of politicians
people that didn't really want to be Paul
politicians people that were kind of doing other
things productive members of society had families
and then ultimately reality or I suppose Democrat
or Progressive reality hit them in the face and
then you felt like you had to get involved so uh
you're on the you're on the campaign bus right now
it looks like the polls are basically neck and
neck like I take it you're feeling pretty good
yeah absolutely right now we're we are tied
in the polls we feel very good we feel like
we have a lot of good momentum like I said on the
ground but even from what we're hearing from the
little the the that we can hear from the media in
locally we're being told that we're not seeing the
crowds at the Whitmer events that we're seeing at
the Dixon events so we know that there is a lot
of energy it's very exciting but but the energy
is because of the lockdowns it's because of the
schools being shut down I mean you heard in the
debate she came out and she said our schools were
only locked down for three months which is a total
lie even even just today at this rally we had a
young man who he must be in high school probably
about 16 17 years old and he said I listened to
her say that I was out of school for a year and
a half in Ann Arbor this is when you have the
students who are the ones that are standing up and
seeing that these politicians are being dishonest
I think that's a really interesting turn because
now politicians have to realize that they're not
just being watched by adults that what they're
doing is being watched by kids because kids have
more access to the news and politics than they
ever have before and so when children are watching
you and they hear you say something dishonest
I mean those those are the folks that are going
to call you out every time right the kids turn
around and they say oh this the governor's lying
and that's what so many parents have come to me
when I said you know I just heard an audible gasp
across Michigan when you when you lied about the
schools being shut down for three months to me
and said that was the thing it was our kids in
this in the family room sitting with us that had
the audible gasp and said no that's not true we
were out for much longer than that this is very
interesting to see this the Democrat Party kind
of trying to they're flailing they're trying to
figure out exactly who their base is and they
seem to have lost their base yeah it was really
a wild moment because she said it you immediately
called her out on it I'm pretty sure I just heard
an audible gasp around town when Gretchen Whitmer
said that kids were out of school for three months
perhaps she wasn't paying attention to what was
actually happening even we even had schools that
were closed this year this is shocking to me that
she thinks that schools were only closed for three
months or maybe she thinks she can convince you
that schools were only closed for three months but
you know better because your students are the
ones that are desperately behind and the test
scores show that she's being dishonest about
this she's being dishonest about even trying
to get into these schools to get these schools
back on track clearly the audience didn't buy
it anyone that's paying any attention didn't buy
it uh I don't know if you know this but in the in
the midst of all that I lived in California at
the time I'm in Florida now but even in Crazy
Cali with our lockdowns I was sending seeds to
people in Michigan because if you remember she
didn't want people to Garden in their own backyard
yards so I was literally sending seeds to people
in Detroit and all over Michigan for that but what
do you make of that that concept that she can bold
face lie like that I mean when you shake her hand
did you shake her hand after like yeah do you say
to her hate lady the cameras aren't on like how do
you do it how do you do it she can do it because
the media comes to her rescue every time they
say I mean well can we technically say that the
schools were only out for three months we I mean
and I just blasted this guy the other day no you
cannot because the schools were out for a year
and a half what are you talking about how could
you possibly hold the water for this politician
but they are definitely in full-blown defense
of her but what you said about the Seas it's very
interesting because I think a lot of people don't
understand what happened in the state of Michigan
she did we actually had sections of our grocery
stores that had police tape around them saying
you can't go into this section and buy this I
had a woman yesterday who said I have a greenhouse
we were stopped from having curbside service for
Easter lilies but she said I said you know I had
a guy in Grand Rapids say the same thing but down
the street they can sell marijuana curbside she
said yeah I think it's the same growing process
but we were stopped and we actually had they
actually had notices on their door that they
would be sent to jail that's how Gretchen Whitmer
operated and another guy just stopped me and this
was really interesting he said don't ever forget
he said I'm a surgeon and don't ever forget that
every surgery was considered an elective surgery
we were shut down from knee Replacements from
broken ankles everything was shut down but the
abortion clinics were open so it was interesting
how that worked it's interesting because there's
a Confluence of the the covid stuff and then what
you started with which was you know the parental
rights sort of thing are you finding that there's
a whole bunch of new people that would not
traditionally be Republicans because that seems to
be the thing that's happening all over the country
look you're going to have your base on either
side but there is this huge wave of I would say
mugged liberals who are just like enough of this
so much so and I brought this up in the debate too
because we have a community in Michigan Dearborn
Michigan that has a strong Democrat base this is
a largely Muslim Community and when I was at one
of our rallies I had a father come to the rally
from Dearborn and he said I just wanted to we we
do these Town Halls where we'll let people ask
us anything and so he said I just want to make
a comment I recently went to my elected officials
in the Democrat Party and I said I don't like this
content that's in our schools and he said I was
called a racist and a bigot and he said that I
had been running for a position I had been running
for elected position as a Democrat and he said I
won't vote Democrat this year and I'm going to
tell everybody in my community that they should
not vote Democrat because the Democrats will not
protect our kids from this stuff and I told this
story at the debate and Stephen Colbert picked
it up and said this never happened all the story
of this man that never existed well the man was
so mad and I think this is what we're going to
start seeing folks that have true concerns that
your elected officials should stand up for that
are being ignored because they're not pushing the
right propaganda and he stood up and he said he
got really mad and he said no when he went to the
local news and he said you know I'm being made fun
of on Stephen Colbert and I give the local news
credit for actually running historians saying no
he actually did stand up at her rally and say this
and that has sort of also put the whole Democrat
Party on their knees because or on their heels
because they're going uh they should be on their
knees maybe at this point um on their heels saying
shoot what are we going to do now that this guy
came forward and said this really is the truth
and the Democrats aren't listening to what the
real issues are but isn't that the problem across
the country they're telling us that the issues we
should have are not the issues we do have I mean
energy Independence oh no no don't worry about
that the Border no no no don't worry about that
focus on these other things no the people know
what to worry about right and then of course it
turned out that in Dearborn Michigan all of these
Muslim parents were at the school board meetings
and some videos did actually really go viral of
them saying hey enough of this indoctrination
so Colbert I always say he's just part of the
machine he just will say whatever whatever they
put out there but speaking of the media there was
a really nice moment after your debate where you
basically just stood there you were surrounded by
probably I don't know 30 reporters and they just
all have the mic in your face and you just like
one at a time answering every single question and
the whole time I was watching it we played some of
it I was thinking is there any chance Whitmer did
anything like that no you know she was over there
but she actually brought in a bunch of elected
officials to stand with her and help her answer
the questions so I don't know exactly what
her media scrum looked like but I know they're
certainly much harder on me they want to they want
to push this narrative they want to help her out
to say gosh this side their conspiracy theorist
I'm like this is hilarious that they're concerned
about the fact that we go back and say well in the
state of Michigan Jocelyn Benson broke a few of
the rules our secretary of state broke a few of
the rules without talking to the legislature at
judge actually came out and said that some of
the things she did in the election were unlawful
and so we of course get hit with that well you
believe that this election was unlawful no a
judge believes that this election was unlawful
it's not me but they're they're like oh we've
got to come up with something to make these
people scary and have them vote against them
the media is literally helping them to try to
create a narrative that does not exist and so
we know when we go into those media scrums that
it's going to be a battle and we're just going
to knock each question out make sure that we get
the questions done and move on do you get invites
for the from mainstream like on CNN or MSNBC or
any of that stuff uh we actually I will say that
um oh maybe not I can't remember if it was CNN or
not but you know in those cases I don't think that
we're gonna be asked the the fair or the nice
questions at this point I 100 know that these
media Outlets are there to try to get Democrats
elected I mean we're at the point now where we
see it they're running stories straight out of the
opposition research book like they've gotten down
to the bottom and they haven't been able to knock
out Republicans so they're putting they're going
to the news and could you run this story we think
there might be some accuracy to it I mean these
are just you know they get a wild hair and they
try to run with it it's not even true is there is
there any coordination between you and some of the
other Republican candidates that are picking up
steam right now I mean if you see what's going on
in New York Lee zeldin who nobody I mean basically
nobody knew of outside of a small District in New
York until about a month ago uh you know Cary lake
is seems to be on fire now in Arizona are you
guys coordinating in any way on message Jing or
anything or you all just kind of doing your own
thing yeah doing our own thing but I Carrie Lake
and I have spoken several times obviously our
states are all a little bit different Michigan
is definitely a state where we are very concerned
about school right now the school system has been
in a steady decline now that we've gotten through
covid and there has been no assistance no tutoring
program in place the schools are now in the bottom
10 in the nation so for us it's really important
to talk to parents about getting schools back
on track getting our kids back on track getting
the tutoring that we need in the classrooms but
then overall in general making sure parents are
involved in the schools and we go from the bottom
10 to the top ten we cannot continue to say we're
going to re-elect politicians that allow us to
continue to stay in the bottom 10 in the nation I
think person whitmer's been in office for 20 years
it's time to hold her accountable actually it's
time to just say move on go to the private sector
see how that works for you well it'll probably
make her a lot of money but that would be better
than the the current situation so I don't think
I've been to to Michigan I was there probably been
about five years I did a couple shows in Grand
Rapids and the crowds were absolutely awesome
but before that I was in Detroit I went to the
GM Center over there what's the building called
the GM Center or GM that building that's the it's
the total recall building I was very excited
to be there it's a very cool building uh but
then obviously if you go outside into Detroit
it's not good to say the least what what can
actually be done because it's been under Democrat
control for for decades I think at this point
and think of the Optics of this she had Barack
Obama here over the weekend and you know when
you're bringing Barack Obama in that means
you need to get your base out so she brought
Barack Obama in and took him into Detroit and he
made fun of the fact that there was crime in the
cities saying you know this is a trump problem
it was unbelievable how glib he was about it
and and think of the Optics of that standing in
the second most violent city in America and saying
re-elect this person continue to have Democrats
running this state it is outrageous well we know
that Gretchen Whitmer marched with the folks that
are carrying the science defund the police she
said she supports the spirit of defund the police
overall when you continually push to defund the
police and you don't honor that position we are
losing police we there was a point in uh maybe a
little bit earlier in summer where newspaper ran
an article saying we've lost a cop a day in the
city of Detroit that's how challenging it is to
get to get police to stay in their positions in
Michigan because they don't have the support
of the chief executive officer we know how
important that is we know that we can bring that
back we're not only going to put money into our
police but we're going to make sure that everybody
in the state knows that they are supported on it
honored and respected by the Dixon Administration
was she always so far left or I don't even know
that it's far left like so government must do
everything all the time and will control every
bit of your life or did this all kind of burst
forth when covet happened oh she's always been
always been a progressive I mean she came out
we have her on tape as a senator coming out and
saying that she wants to get rid of ice she wants
to abolish ice very clearly yes I want to abolish
ice she also voted against a ban on partial birth
abortion so we know that where she's always stood
in the same place there and don't forget that
not too far a lot not too far back when she was
a state senator she wanted to vote against right
for right to work and so she opened the doors of
the Capitol even though they were locked and they
were trying to keep the legislators safe from from
the protesters she opened the doors to the Capitol
in fact there's even a story that she helped to
open a side window to the Capitol and let the
protesters in and then she went on tape and and
in her 2018 campaign when she was on the debate
stage we're on a news interview she said I threw
open the doors of the Capitol and let the people
in I mean this is pretty radical when you know the
state police have it locked down and are trying
to keep the legislators safe to open the doors
and have all these protesters come into the
capitol so this has always been who she is
she's a radical Progressive she's also trying
to shut down a pipeline in the state of Michigan
she is on board with the and the anti-American
energy message she's been trying to shut down the
pipeline the entire time she's been in office she
has a lawsuit still out there it would decimate
the state of Michigan it would kill our economy it
would raise prices to heat homes it's a terrible
terrible situation we have to protect the State
against these radical Progressive policies yeah
that actually was the next question I want to ask
you because obviously with GM there and so much
of the automotive industry coming from Michigan
and Detroit uh this push from the administration
against fossil fuels and all of this stuff I
mean this is sort of a direct assault on you guys
oh absolutely and we so we have people in the
state certainly in the businesses manufacturing
manufacturers use a lot of energy we see that
the binding Administration wants to shut down
sources of energy Gretchen Whitmer is on board
with shutting down those sources of energy so
I've had multiple people come to me whether they
are folks that live in the Upper Peninsula of
Michigan or manufacturers all across the state
who are saying to me can you assure us that you
will not have a Gavin Newsom approach approach
to energy because we're considering leaving the
state of Michigan because we know Gretchen Whitmer
wants to be the most Progressive Energy governor
in the country and we've already seen Gavin
Newsom say he's Banning gas vehicles we are
deathly afraid that that's going to happen in the
state of Michigan and I've assured people that is
not how we will manage the state of Michigan
and if you want to make sure that you have the
energy sources that we have always had and that
we increase that you have to vote for addiction
Administration do you know what the numbers
are in terms of people fleeing Michigan you
know you don't hear about it like Cali in New York
obviously but I'm guessing that you must have lost
a decent amount of people during covet so many
that we actually lost a congressional seat so
we were one of the states that lost yes yes it is
significant and when I go around the state I have
multiple businesses saying to me hey look we're
building new factories but it's not going to be
in Michigan the regulatory state is a nightmare
Gretchen whitmer's Administration has ramped that
up been really tough on business across the
board not just covet across the board so when
I talk to our businesses they're like sorry but
we're actually building new facilities in Texas
or we're already moving to Indiana that's the last
thing we want is to see our businesses going down
to down South we want to make sure that we are the
place that they want to build expand and stay and
I believe that we can do that all right so since
everyone can see you're on the tour bus where
are you headed for the last couple days and uh I
guess go ahead and make a prediction why not huh
yeah we're all over the state so we're going to
be I'm spending a lot of time in the next day
in the southeast part of Michigan we're going
to go back over to West Michigan we're going to
travel as much as we can to meet as many people
as possible through the state we just came from
northern Michigan so we'll be making another
loop around but honestly I it's interesting
because like I said just the feeling on the ground
when you look at her crowds when you look at our
crowds when you look at the social media posts it
seems like this neck and neck race is potentially
going our way there are definitely a lot of a lot
of quiet Republicans out there we have the people
that are Whispering all the time I'm voting for
you I'm voting for you so I feel like we'll have
a pretty good night on Tuesday all right my cards
are on the table I wish you good luck Tudor and
uh I hope to talk to you soon once you're once
you're a governor how about that that sounds
like a plan thank you if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics watch our
full episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be sure
to subscribe and click the notification Bell